Крістофу Гюбнеру найкраще працюється з видом на Таллін.
35-річний підприємець продає медичні страховки.
Він з'їхав зі своєї квартири в Німеччині і зареєстрував компанію в Естонії.
Відтоді став "цифровим кочівником" - подорожує світом,
мешкає в орендованих квартирах "AirBnB" та веде бізнес телефоном або електронною поштою.
Я прилетів зі Стамбула. Доти цілий місяць був на Кіпрі. Я постійно щось трохи змінюю.
Як і всі приватні підприємці в Естонії, Крістоф Гюбнер може вирішувати всі справи через інтернет.
Три роки тому уряд запустив програму, за допомогою якої
кожен може стати "цифровим резидентом" цієї країни.
Відтоді - навіть без переїзду в Естонію - кожен може кількома кліками відкрити власну компанію.
Без бюрократії та купи довідок.
За три роки Естонія отримала 15 мільйонів євро доходів від цієї програми.
З них лише півтора мільйона євро надійшло безпосередньо у вигляді податків.
Решту ми отримали як непрямі прибутки.
Адже коли ви стаєте "цифровим резидентом", з'являється потреба у віртуальному офісі,
віртуальному секретарі, бізнес- або податковому консультанті.
Консалтингова компанія Deloitte прогнозує, що до 2025 року "цифрові мешканці"
принесуть Естонії мільярд вісімсот мільйонів євро прибутку.
Потужний кон'юнктурний двигун для невеличкої країни.
А от для Німеччини це дуже віддалена перспектива.
На жаль - кажуть в пофільній телекомунікаційній асоціації.
Економіка Німеччини не може собі дозволити відмовлятися від можливостей,
які пропонує дигіталізація, в тому числі й заради забезпечення нашого майбутнього добробуту.
Приклад Естонії та її цифрового громадянства,
за допомогою якого можна відкрити власний бізнес лише кількома кліками мишки,
може слугувати для нас прикладом для наслідування.
До дигіталізації в Естонії привчають змалку -
програмування вже давно стало обов'язковим предметом у школах.
На комп'ютерах учні пишуть власні ігри або музичні програми.
Але що казати про школи - у Естонії навіть новонароджені громадяни
одразу знайомляться із сучасною цифровою реальністю.
ID-картку з чіпом дитині видають одразу після пологів .
І молоді батьки прямо у палаті пологового будинку самостійно реєструють свого малюка.
Тепер, коли ми зареєструвати ім’я сина,
ми можемо у цій же системі подати заявку на отримання допомоги на дитину,
на сімейну допомогу, на допомогу в декреті і також на всі документи.
Кожен, хто під'єднався до системи електронного громадянства,
може у власному цифровому кабінеті побачити,
які їхні документи і з якою метою використовували державні установи.
Робиться це, щоб створити довіру між громадянами та державою.
Ми свято переконані, що люди повинні довіряти системі,
а задля цього система повинна бути прозорою.
Саме тому ми зробили всі дані відкритими.
Крім того, кожен документ від самого початку створюється лише в цифровому вигляді.
Ми не маємо жодних паперових копій.
Система електронного державного управління показує обмін онлайн-документами
між різними відомствами та службами.
Естонці вже давно не носять довідки в пенсійний фонд або у дитячі садочки.
Проте навіть така система подачі заявок в інтернеті
вже не задовольняє молодих естонських реформаторів.
Саме на 2019-й рік в Естонії запланували черговий етап створення "невидимого уряду".
В ідеальному світі, коли невидимий уряд повністю запрацює,
після народження дитини батьки взагалі не повинні будуть подавати жодних заявок онлайн:
ані на декрет, ні на першу-другу дитину, ані записуватися в дитячий садочок чи реєструвати ім’я.
Усі ці речі, які роблять різні служби,
будуть автоматично здійснюватися і передаватися далі у системі.
І це почне діяти у нас в Естонії навесні 2019-го.
Мільйон триста тисяч мешканців Естонії мають доступ до інтернету -
будь-де та будь-коли і - безкоштовно.
Це право їм гарантоване державою з 2000 року.
А от Німеччина у цьому плані ще доволі відстала - інтернет працює далеко не всюди.
А швидкісне інтернет-з’єднання і досі є фактично лише у містах.
Нині ситуація така, що значна частина території Німеччини - 20% - це ліси.
Тож перш, ніж ми почнемо забезпечувати високошвидкісним інтернетом лисиць і птахів,
треба зробити домашню роботу в тих селах і сільських районах,
які досі не охоплені нормальним інтернетом.
А швидкісне з'єднання стане вже наступним кроком.
Тож, з точки зору поширення та якості інтернету Естонія досі залишається піонеркою,
а також прикладом для наслідування для б агатьох країн, зокрема - і Німеччини.